You guys have to see this for a very brief
period of time.
It started to maybe look like Donald Trump
would consider conceding to Joe Biden, accepting
that he lost to Joe Biden.
We heard that Melania and Jared Kushner were
supposedly telling Donald Trump, you might
want to look at conceding.
This seems to have.
Done a 180 yesterday with some absurd triggered
tweets from Donald Trump claiming that he
won essentially all of the key battleground
states for this election.
Trump also sent out his press secretary, Kayleigh
McEnany, as well as RNC chair Ronna McDaniel,
plus a lawyer to some room in a hotel to claim
that the fight will continue for a long time.
We'll talk about that a little bit later.
It's starting to be beyond belief that this
is even happening.
But take a look at these tweets.
Trump first tweeting about Nevada, saying
Nevada is turning out to be a cesspool of
fake votes.
Ms. Schlapp and Adam Laxalt are finding things
that, when released, will be absolutely shocking.
Now, that tweet was flagged as misinformation
by Twitter.
Joe Biden is currently winning in Nevada by
36000 votes.
That's about three percent.
It's not even in recount territory in Nevada.
Trump then goes on to Wisconsin.
Trump tweeting, quote, Wisconsin is looking
very good, needs a little time statutorily,
will happen soon.
Trump claiming, I guess, that he's going to
win Wisconsin.
Now, the margin in Wisconsin is about 20000
votes.
This is the same margin by which Donald Trump
won in 2016.
He didn't complain then, but now he's complaining.
Then Donald Trump goes on to Pennsylvania
tweeting, quote, Pennsylvania prevented us
from watching much of the ballot count unthinkable
and illegal in this country.
Now, Twitter also flagged that as disinformation.
The lead in Pennsylvania for Joe Biden has
grown to 45000 votes and both Republican and
Democratic poll watchers were allowed to oversee.
Trump is lying.
And then Trump going on to Georgia saying,
quote, Georgia will be a big presidential
win as it was the night of the election.
Now, as of this moment, Georgia has not been
called, but Biden's lead there has grown to
12000 votes.
Now, as I said earlier on in the program,
there's no doubt that these are thin margins
in some states, mostly still larger margins
than Trump had in 2016.
But this is delusional and completely humiliating
at this point.
Donald Trump claiming he's going to win states
he didn't win.
When, how?
And if you actually ask, as we saw in the
press conference yesterday with Kayleigh McEnany,
if you actually say, do you have proof of
specific fraudulent or illegal votes?
The answer is not yes.
They go off into well, we weren't given access
and.
Well, then why are you suspecting that that
happened?
Well, we just need to let the courts play
well.
But why do courts need to be involved if you
don't actually have evidence yet?
A lot of that came up during this Gong Show
press conference with Kayleigh McEnany, which
was so pathetic and lie riddled that even
Fox News had to cut away.
Let's discuss that next.
And then later, we'll get we'll get into the
growing theory that the current president,
the last gasp president has with Fox News.